oh this better not be that good moving
well I know there are many secrets and
why don't I gotta go for it
don't like crying okay so dad so Morgan
ever since till I was about a year old
and we got her her first haircut I've
kept all of the hair and I have had it
made into a small hair doll to remember
her youth by oh that's really great she
needed to shoot how do you put like pins
in it it's like very Buddhist it's not a
voodoo doll hair dolls whether it's a
head of some moms make breast milk
jewelry but I didn't save my breast milk
so I was able to do that this is what I
can tell what time you never show this
to me because it's kind of embarrassing
but it gets fine yeah
I understand the maternal instinct I
live with one for a long freakin time I
live with my dad I used to race cars and
I definitely caught the gene from you
because I used to race the Integra down
Monterey Pass Road and I didn't get got
well I just would want to know what was
the fastest speed you know if you ever
went faster than I did I only went up to
100
does that make you happy I'm not
disappointed or anything like that
that's pretty cool I'm going to be
living with a tribe that's on the Amazon
River we're going to take a canoe and
then we have to I think we have to walk
like 10 miles are you prepared for that
and like that it can be a little bit
dangerous and they're going to be naked
so I'm going to have to just be there
with them
negative probably I mean that's they
told me that I have to kind of fit into
the thing I probably won't have any
phones I'm not going to be able to to
talk to you probably but it's for eight
months but it's a really great
opportunity that's alone I want to worry
about you fantastic mom it's gonna be a
really hard sphere for her I think you
need that the secret to the secret is
that it's not real oh it's not real oh I
was all proud of he's got a hundred
miles an hour Town Car you pass Brooke
look like the travel back in time I
wouldn't do it now so I'm not actually
going to the Amazon River and I made the
whole thing up and that wasn't really my
secret and then I don't really have a
secret to tell you
yeah you lied to me I call you dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde she's very good now
I know your range as an actor there is
one more time that is a lie I totally
don't do that
I would never do that I feel money I do
feel so supported dad I was just as
nervous mind to you as I was if I really
did have to tell you that big of a
secret it turns out there were you more
worried about me having to be naked than
the yeah virus I mean hello my daughter
naked in front of everybody hello this
is a porno what